وطابت اوقاتكم واهلا بكم الى هذه الساعه
الاخباريه والتي نخصص معظمها لتغطيه
التطورات في السودان واخر الاحداث دائما
الى العناو
رغم الهدنه اشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله في
ام درمان وطائرات الجيش تحلق في سماء
الخرطوم
نقابه الاطباء السودانيه تعلن توقف كل
مستشفيات الخرطوم عن العمل وتحذر من الوضع
في دارفور
مع استمرار المواجهات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع روسيا تجلي اكثر من 200 شخص من
السودان
ونتابع ايضا في هذه الاخبار
الفصائل الفلسطينيه تعلن الاضراب الشامل
ردا على وفاه الاسير عدنان خضر في سجون
اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم رغم الهدنه المعلنه بين الجيش
والدعم السريع والحديث عن مفاوضات مرتقبه
بين طرفي الصراع وقعت اشتباكات عنيفه صباح
اليوم في مدن سودانيه ابرزها الخرطوم
واندرمان في وقت تتفاقم الازمه الصحيه حيث
خرجت كل المستشفيات الخرطوم عن العمل
بينما تعاني المنشات من نقص نحات في
المستلزمات الطبيه لم يتوقف الامر عند هذا
الحد حيث بات خطر الجوع والنزوح يخيم على
مستقبل السودانيين
لازم اشتغل يعني في الظروف
السلع في زياده اي حاجه لازم انا اشتغل
لي زي ساعتين ثلاثه وقفل لانه البلد ما
امنا
لازم واحد تخاطر بنفسه يحاول يستغل القواد
ما حبابه والحوض
[موسيقى]
التفاصيل اكثر حيث افاد مراسل العربيه في
السودان عن سماع يدويه اسلحه ثقيله
للاشتباكات بين قوات الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع في منطقه المهندسين بام
درمان حيث حلق طيران الجيش السوداني في
مدن الخرطوم الثلاث واستهدف مواقع لقوات
الدعم السريع واكد المراسل على استمرار
الاشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم في
منطقه كافوري بالخرطوم بحري فيما شنا
طيران الجيش السوداني قصفا جويا في ولايه
شرق النيل وافقى المراسل ياتي ذلك في
وقتنا اعلنت سلطات الطيران المدني
السوداني تمديد اغلاق المجال الجوي
باستثناء طائرات الاجلاء والمساعدات
هذا واظهرت صور تحليقا للطائرات الحربيه
التابعه للجيش في سماء العاصمه الخرطوم
حيث استهدفت مواقعها وتمركزت تمركزت فيها
قوات الدعم السريع
[تصفيق]
وفي كلمته امام المندوبين الدائمين في
الجامعه العربيه الذي الذين عقدوا اجتماعا
في القاهره لبحث الاوضاع في السودان جدد
فهد الخمعلي النائب المندوب الدائم
للسعوديه لدى الجامعه العربيه الدعوه دعوه
بلاده لايقاف المواجهات في السودان للحفاظ
على حياه المدنيين ان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
تجدد دعوتها لسرعه وقف العمليات العسكريه
والتحلي باقصى درجات ضبط النفس وتجنب
التصعيد وتغليف مصلحه الشعب السوداني
للحفاظ على مكتسباته ومقدراته والعوده الى
الاتفاق الايطالي الذي يهدف الى الوصول
الى اعلان سياسي يحقق الامن والاستقرار
للسودان وشعبه الشقيق
وتؤكد المملكه على اهميه الالتزام بالهدنه
القائمه وحمايه المدنيين والبعثات
الدبلوماسيه وتوفير الممرات الامنه
للعاملين في المجال الانساني كما تؤكد
المملكه على ضروره العمل على تيسير وتامين
عمليات الاجلاء للمدنيين
في سياق قال محمد مصطفى عرفي مندوب مصر
الدائم لدى الجامعه العربيه على ضروره وقف
اطلاق النار فورا في السودان
اننا نؤكد من هنا باسم رئاسه المجلس على
ضروره الوقف الفوري غير المشروط للعنف
واتاحه الفرصه كامله لانجاح جهود التسويه
وجعلها تؤتي ثمارها في القريب العاجل
ونحذر من هنا باسم رئاسه المجلس من ان
المساس بالمدنيين بالسودان واستهداف
منشاتهم لا سيما الطيبيه منها هو امر خطير
للغايه ويمثل انتهاكا واضحا وسافرا
للقانون الدولي والقانون الدولي الانساني
من جانبه اكد امجد العضايله مندوب الاردن
لدى الجامعه العربيه ان كافه الاطراف في
السودان عليها التحلي بالمسؤوليه مشددا
على ضروره ايجاد حل داخلين سوداني يعكس
تطلعات السودانيين بعيدا عن اي تدخلات
خارجيه
ونؤكد ضروره تحلي كافه الاطراف بروح
المسؤوليه الوطنيه واعلاء المصالح العليا
للسوداني وشعبه الشقيق فوق اي اعتبار اخر
حقنا لدماء السودانيين وتفاديا لقتال بين
ابناء الشعب الواحد لن يكون المنتصر فيها
الا خاسرا فالقاتل والمقتول اخوه والثمن
المدفوع امن واستقرار ومنعت السوداني
واستقلاله ووحدته ووحدته ودماء ابنائه
ونؤكد ان اي حل للازمه الراهنه لابد ان
يكون حلا داخليا سودانيا يعكس اراده
وتطلعات الشعب السوداني الشقيق
بعيدا عن اي تدخلات خارجيه
وكانت الكاميرا العربيه جوله مع المواطنين
السودانيين في بعض احياء الخرطوم للوقوف
على مدى تاثير واقع الاشتباكات والمعارك
على حياتهم نتابع
خمسه اطفال والله الواحد كان مواطن سوداني
يعني بيتالم
قلم شديد جدا جدا الوضع الحاطي في البلد
وانا يعني ما اقدر اقول يعني اقوم اقول
انه البلد فيها
نحن ما حنقول ولا حنقول علان نحن الحصه
وطن الحصه نحن مع الجيش مع البرهان في
الان بعد داخل المحاسبه ممكن تجي
خدمات من الثوره لحد الان ورجعت الحرب
بنهايه الخدمات تماما غياب تام للجيش
وغياب تامل الامن وحتحصل اكثر من كذا نحن
مع البيجي يسلحنا هنا في الاحياء بنقف
معاهم الوضع كله جايط والحمد لله الظروف
ذي ما شايف يعني الشوارع فاضيه كيف
ما في ناس ما في محلات فاتحه
يعني حتى احنا عشان نطلع نشتغل
البنزين مشكله بالنسبه لنا
ينضم الينا الصحفي محمد اسحاق وعثمان من
الخرطوم بحري بالسيد محمد اهلا بك يعني
دعني اسالك اولا عن الاوضاع الميدانيه هل
الهدوء الحذر هو السماء البارزه الان في
بحري
نعم لا دال الهدوء يسيطر على منطقه
الخرطوم بحري كما ذكرت المناطق التي تجاوب
جسم الذي شهد في الايام الماضيه
اكثر من المعارك الشريسه كما ذكرت قبل
قليل في الخبر الذي ولد قبل قليل لا زالت
الطائرات تحلق الان في سماء الخرطوم
البحري وكما ذكرت كنا عندما نسمع اصوات
هذه الطائرات سريعا ما نسمع اصوات
المضادات الارضيه الخاصه بقوات الدعم
السريع تعمل بمجرد سماع عزيز هذه الطائرات
ولكن الان الصوره اراها قد اختلفت بعد
الشيء
اصوات هذه المضادات الارضيه
دلاله ربما وتاكيد على الحديث الذي ذكره
الجيش بالامس بان هذه المعارك ستكون معارك
حاسمه يبدو اننا دخلنا الان في مرحله كسر
العظم كما يطلقون عليها طيله الليل
الطيران يشن هجوما عنيفا اضافه للمواقع
ذكرتها الفا فيما يلي منطقه كافوري ومنطقه
الجسر الشمبان ابو عسكر المظلات نعم محمد
دعني اسالك اليوم ما هو بنك الاهداف لهذا
الطيران الذي يستهدف بعض المواقع لما يقال
انها تمركز لقوات الدعم السريع اشرت الى
بعضها ماذا عن المجمل اليوم هل فقط تحليق
ام سمعتم
صوت قصف
نعم لم نستمع الى ذوي او صوت قصف ولكن
يبدو بانها عمليه تنشيط اعلن عنها الجيش
سابقا بان اليوم سيشهد عمليه تنشيط كبيره
جدا على مستوى الارض وعلى مستوى الجيش
يتحدث الجيش بل ويتخوف من ان تاتي امدادات
لهذه القوات من خارج ولايه القرطوم يتحدث
الجيش بانه الان يحكم الخناق على حدوث
ولايه الخرطوم من الجو ولعلها هي
استكشافيه هذه المره يتحدث عن تغشيط داخل
الاحيان ان هناك جيوب تطوف داخل الاحياء
محليه بحري بالتحديد في منطقه شمباء تكثر
هذه القوات هناك وايضا في واحد من الشوارع
الرئيسيه التي تم استهدافه بالامس الشهيد
المطر او شارع الانقاذ هذا الشارع تكثر
فيه الحركه لاكوات الدعم السريع بل هناك
بعض ارتكازات في هذه المنطقه
هذا هو المبرر الرئيسي ربما لحركه الطيران
الاستكشافيه هي حركه استكشافيه اكثر من
انها حركه قتاليه اظنها كذلك في هذا
الصباح لاننا لم نستمع حتى سحب الدخان هل
كانت تسهر الان اراها قد تضع مما يعني بان
هذا الطيران يعمل الان على عمليه استكشاف
للمنطقه لكم الولايات الخرطوم طيب اليوم
نحن نتحدث ايضا عن ربما كان هناك حديث عن
تحركات
وتبديل لمواقع دعم السريع هل شاهدتم هكذا
اشتباكات على الارض على الاقل يوم ليله
امس واليوم
اليوم حتى هذه اللحظه لم نسمع ذوي او صوت
الرصاص
دوما في في ساعات الصباح حتى يعني لا نذهب
بعيدا دوما في ساعات الصباح تكون الامور
اكثر هدوءا ولكن ننتظر بعض الظهر بالتحديد
تبدا العمليه هكذا تعودنا يعني من خلال
الايام
السابقه تبدا بعد فتره الظهر تبدا هذه
العمليات ولكن حتى الان لا حديث او لا صوت
نسمعه في هذه اللحظات من صوت طلقات او صوت
دوليه طيله الليل كنا نستمع لهذه الاصوات
بقوه وانفجارات
ربما بعد تواصلنا مع بعض المصادر علمنا
بان هذه
الانفجارات من منطقه
المعسكر المظلات الذي هو بالقرب من جسر
الشنبات وكذلك منطقه كارفوري التي شهدت
احتدام عنيف جدا لهذه العمليات خصوصا بعد
التدمير هذا المستودع هذا المخزن الذي كان
يحتوي على مجموعه من السخائر
في منطقه كافوري طيب اليوم نتحدث عن ايضا
الوضع الانساني في هذه المنطقه هل من
حركات النزوح دائما ما يكون هناك تحذير من
ان موجه نزوح قد تكون قادمه اذا ما استمر
الوضع والقتال كما هو عليه
نعم لاحظت قبل قليل في منطقه جسر الحلفايه
وجود هذه الحافلات الان الحاضها بكثافه ز
اد هذه الحافلات مما يدل على ان
الخروج من ولايه الخرطوم لا زالت هي واحده
من مت
طلبه المواطنين بالتحديد هنا في بحر هذه
نقطه تجمع نقطه جسر الحلفايه تعتبر من
النقاط الكبيره
للتجمع بعد رحول هذه الحافلات من منطقه
الشمبان موقفها الرئيسي كذا محدد الى
منطقه جسر الحلفايه الاحظ بهذه اللحظات
عدد كبير من الحفلات الضم الى منطقه
الحلفايه فيما يلي الجانب الاخر مساله
المياه كذلك لا تزال هي الشغل الشاقي
الرقم حديث السيد والي الخرطوم الذي
تحدثنا معه بان الان يجري اصلاح واحدا من
المحطات الكبيره اللي هي محطه بحري
المعروفه الكهرباء كانت تشكل حاجزا الان
بدات تعود تدريجيا لبعض الاحياء هناك فرق
الصيانه شاهدناها بانها تطوف احياء بحري
المختلفه لاصلاح هذه الاعطاب التي تسبب او
تسببت في هذه الاشتباكات المتفرقه عدا ذلك
المحلات الان اعاده من جديد تفتح ابوابها
كانت هناك اشكاليه في الخبز بصوره واضحه
من خلال هذه الطوابير الطويله التي تغتص
حول البخابز الان بدات بعض البخاري تدخل
في الخدمه مما قلل قليلا من هذه الضغوطات
على المواطن واصبح هناك خيارات اخرى لعدد
من اكثر من اثنين او ثلاثه من المخابز
نراها الان هناك بعض الاسواق ولكن عليها
ضغط وازدحام
غير المنطقه
نعم
شكرا جزيلا
للصحفي محمد اسحاق عثمان انضم الينا من
الخرطوم البحري شكرا جزيلا
مخاوف من تفقم الاوضاع في غرب السودان
اعلن حاكم اقليم دارفور من ارك ميناوي عن
التوصل للاتفاق شعبي في ولايه غرب دارفور
لوقف القتال القبلي ودعمناوي عبر حسابه
على تويتر القبائل في غرب دارفور لعدم
الانصياع لاي تعصب قبلي ونشدهم بالحفاظ
على النسيج الاجتماعي وشهدت مدينه الجنينه
بولايه غالب ديار اشتباكات بين قبيله
المساليد والقبائل العربيه اثر الصراع بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في المدينه
اوقعت اكثر من 90 قتيلا
من اقليم دارفور ينضم الينا الصحفي صالح
ابو علامه صالح اهلا بك بدايه لاسالك اولا
عن الاوضاع هل هي هادئه
نعم دعنا اولا نبدا من الاوضاع في جنوب
دارفور مدينه نيالا كما نشاهد ونتابع هذا
هو اليوم الثالث بفتح سوق مدينه نيالا سوق
الجنوبي في مدينه نيالا وسوق الخضر
والفاكهه الحركه تبدو طبيعيه هنا في هذا
السوق بعد مبادرات مجتمعيه
ورسميه ادت الى تهدئه الامور بين الجيش
والدعم السريع تجري الان المبادرات
التوقيع على اتفاق
بين الجيش والدعم السريع
طمانينه للمواطن هنا في جنوب دارفور
عاشها هنا
مليئه بالقتال ومليئه ايضا بالسلب والنهب
لعدد من الممتلكات
في هذه
الولايه تدمير كبير للمخازن مخازن الغذاء
العالمي ومخازن الدقيق عدد ايضا من
المنشات الحكوميه الرسميه
وايضا منظمات اجنبيه
صالح
طيب يبدو اننا سنعود مره اخرى الى صالح
حيثما
يصلح هذا الخلل من المصدر نكمل معكم هذه
النشره في حديث خاصه مع العربيه قال
المبعوث الاماميه الى السودان فولكر بيرتز
ان العمل جاري لوضع التفاصيل اللوجستيه
للمفاوضات السودان مع الامريكيين
والسعوديين ورجح ان تجرى المفاوضات
مفاوضات الحل في السعوديه اداره
الاعمال الفنيه هلا مع الامريكان
والسعوديين فبطئت بالارجح
سيتم بالمحاز بالارجخ طبعا يعني الجانبين
لازم ان يوافقوا على
هذا المكان وانا ما بحكي هلا عن تفوت
سياسي انا بحكي عن محادثات حول حلول فنيه
الى هذه المعاه
لانشاء وتاسيس اليه
لوقفه لاك نار دائم وثابت مع اليه مراقبه
والتحكم على وقفه لكن
في متابعه للاوضاع الطبيه خلال سكرتيره
نقابه الاطباء السودانيه عطيه عبد الله ان
الوضع الصحي كارثي واصفا ما يحدث في
القطاع الطبي بالجريمه الانسانيه واضاف ان
كل المستشفيات العامه في الخرطوم توقفت عن
العمل حيث ادعى اطراف الصراع لوقف القتال
فورا واكد ان الوضع الصحي كارثي في
الجنينه بدارفور محذرا من الوضع نفسه في
باقي الولايات اذا ما استمرت المواجهات
وقال ان مستشفيات خرجت من الخدمه بسبب عدم
توفر
الوقود
الاوضاع في الجنينه كارثيه للغايه نعم
النظام الصحي لازال يتهاوى في كل لحظه
وحين بالامس عدد من المستويات خرجت خارج
الخدمه لانه لم نستطيع ايصال كوادر طبيه
اليها وبعض الاخر خرج من الخدمه لانقطاع
الوقود الجازلين وايضا هنالك يعني عدد من
الولايات تعاني من نقص في الاكسجين حتى في
ولايه الخرطوم
العوامل مجتمعه وهو ما ظللنا نحذر منه منذ
اليوم الاول ستؤدي الى الى نتيجه لا
نتمناها ابدا وهي انهيار النظام الصحيه
نحن نتخوف ان يحدث مع يعني يحصل ما حدث في
الجنينه في عدد من المدن وهو ما تخوف عنه
لذلك نحن مطالبتنا لطرفي الصراع الان هي
ايقاف هذه الحرب داخل ولايه الخرطوم هنالك
مستشفيات توقفت تماما لانه ما فيها معينات
طبيه
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا الدكتور محمد
ابراهيم عبد الرحمن المتحدث باسم وزاره
الصحه في السودان دكتور اهلا بك اولا
تقييمك لعمل المستشفيات في الخرطوم لنتحدث
عنها اولا هل بالفعل كل المستشفيات توقفت
وخرجت عن الخدمه
للجرحى
نشيد بالقطاع الصحي
المنظم والمتطوعين في هذه الملحمه الوطنيه
[موسيقى]
ابدا بالاعداد الاصابات ولا بالمصيفات
الشغاله او طيب نبدا نبدا باعداد الاصابات
الاصابات اليوم تحديثها نعم نعم اليوم لا
توجد اصابات
[موسيقى]
ولكن يوم امس كانت الملك 8 اصابات لا توجد
وفيات مسجله لمستشفيات لليوم ولا يوم امس
ولا اول امس طيب عدد الاصابات التراكمي
يوم 15 وحتى فجر اليوم هو 3,13 حاله 1288
من صفات القطاع العام وال 1725 مستشفى
مجموع عدد الوفيات الموثقه في المستشفيات
والتي اتت مستشفى او او لتاكيد الوفاه
هذه الارقام تخص ولايه خلطون فقط 93
القطاع العام 113 من صفات اللقاح الخاصه
مجموع العمليات الكبيره التي اجريت في هذه
الفتره وحتى فجر اليوم هي 523 عمليه كبيره
لاستخراج الرصاص
والظائف العائله يعني هذه الارقام لا تشمل
الامراض المزمنه والعمليات
العاجله للامراض المزمنه 490
حاله الخاص الحالات الخطر التي ما زالت في
العنايه المكثفه هي 61
مراكز غسيل الكلى والتي تقدم الخدمه الى
4000 مريض غسيل الكيل الطاري والاجل 24
مركز من مجمل 30 مركز سيقدم الخدمه منذ
يوم 15 وحتى وحتى اليوم المراكز الصحيه
المرجعيه والتي تراجع اصحاب الامراض
المزمنه وتحويلهم الى المستشفيات الطرفيه
وشبهه الطرفيه والمركزيه الامنه هي 151
مركز من مجمل 81 مركز موزع جغرافيا على
المحليات المكونه لمخرطوم عدد مستشفيات
ولايه الخرطوم التي تحت حاكميه الوزاره
134 مستشفى 53 مستشفى القطاع العام و81
مستشفى القطاع الخاص وهنالك 11 مستشفى
لا تنتمي الى حاكميه وزاره الصحه هي
مستشفيات الجيش والشرطه والعمل والجامعات
وهي عدد 11 مستشفى جميعها تعمل
ماذا عن المستشفيات التي تحت حكيميه وزاره
الصحه هل هي تعمل بكامل طاقتها
اليوم هي 39 مستشفى هذه المستشفيات هي في
مناطق الاشتباكات حتى لتاريخ اليوم مناطق
غير امنه هي المستشفيات التي متاخمه لمصر
وشارع
المطار والقياده والازاحه ومركز ومركز
البحري مركز منطقه بحريه 39 مستشفى
هذه هي الاحصائيه
اخي المتحدث نحن سمعناه اخي الكريم لا
توجد في السودان
النغابه مسجله في مكتب المكتب العام
لتسجيل نقابات عمال للسودان لا توجد بما
يسمى نقابه اطباء السودان وهنالك مسمى
باللجنه التمهيديه اذا هذه اللجنه
التمهيديه تؤكد انه لا توجد نظافه منذ
الثوره الشعب المجيده ثوره ديسمبر لا توجد
نقابه الان حقيقيه على ارض الواقع هذه
مسميات اسيريه وهنالك اجسام كانت تحل محل
هذه النغابه ايضا اجسام تطوعيه
الاطباء واللجنه الشرعيه للاختصاصيين
والمكتب الموحد للاختصاصين والان ظهرت
نقابه نقابه بالوضع الشرعي لها دورها في
هذه الملحمه لا توجد لا توجد مغابه الان
مسجله لدى المكتبه العام لتسجيل عماله
السوداني
ان يكون واضحا لدى هذه القنوات التي تتلقى
معلوماتها من اجسام غير حقيقيه هذه
الارقام غير حقيقيه
انا ادعو اخي الكريم كان لديه قاعده اطباء
فليدعوهم للمشاركه في هذه الملحمه
الانسانيه الوطنيه ان ينزلوا الى هذه
المستشفيات هذه المستشفيات تقدم الخدمه
بالحد الادنى الذي يضمن تقديم الخدمات
الطريه
يا دكتور
محمد
تسمعني دكتور محمد
هل تسمعني يا دكتور محمد اذا ما هي ابرز
التحديات امام هذه المستشفيات اليوم نتحدث
عن الوقود عن
المخزون الطبي ماذا ايضا
طيب الان نحن لا نقول العمل يسير بصوره
جيده ولكن بالقدر الذي يضمن تقديم الخدمات
الطارئه وجبه طارئه وهزيمه وهذه سياسات
واجراءات اداره الازمه معروفه لكل العالم
لكل شانه من يعرف الشان الصحي
صعوبه الحركه صعوبه الحركه لتوف يل
البيانات
كثيره التردد وهذه تكون متاخمه وهذه تبع
مستشفيات محدده لدينا استفدنا من الهدى
السابقه بقدر اي مكان لتوصيل مخزون
الاغذيه لتوفير مخزون من الاكسجين الذي
يتحدث عنه الاخ الكريم لتوفير الادويه
والمايلات نحن لدينا مخزون استراتيجي يكفي
لهذه الازمه خاصه مع تدني الترددات
نحن نحن الان نعد العده لما بعد الازمه
يعني تعدون العده حتى افهم يا دكتور محمد
تسير بصوره مقدره على دكتور محمد حتى
استفيد من من وجودك اذا تكرمت الان حضرتك
تقول بان هناك
المستشفيات تقدم الخدمات ولو كان بالحد
الادنى يعني ليس هناك كما كما وصفها
سكرتير سكرتير نقابه الاطباء السودانيه
عطيه عبد الله بانه خرجت عن الخدمه
وهو مره يقول خرجت عن الخدمه ومره يقول في
نفس
يا سيدي
الامر الواقع اذا تكرمت
طيب هذه اللجنه نفسها هي التي عنك اللجنه
ارجوك ابلغني عن المستشفيات والوضع الطبي
يا دكتور
هذه اللجنه الدكتور محمد هل من الممكن ان
نترك هذه القناه يا دكتور يا دكتور محمد
ارجو ان تستمع لي اذا سمحت هل من الممكن
ان تعطيني حقيقه الامر
بشان هذه المستشفيات هل هي تعمل بالطاقه
القصوى لديها هل تقدم هذه الخدمات
بالحد الذي يقدم الخدمه الطاريه وجبهه
الطارئه هذه استراتيجيات اداره الازمه في
حروب ليس هناك ليس هناك مستشفيات خرجت عن
الخدمه دكتور محمد
دكتور ارجوك اخي الكريم دكتور دعني اكمل
هذه المعلومات دعني من اي جسم اخر تتحدث
عنه واعطيني الحقائق اذا تكرمت يا دكتور
اعطيك تفضل وزاره النظام الصحي في السودان
هنالك 18 ولايه مكونات للجمهوريه السودان
ولايه الخرطوم واحد على 18
مجموع المستشفيات السودان 8 المستشفى على
القطاعين العام والخاص واضح لا تشمل هذه
المستشفيات من صفات الجيش والشرطه والامن
المتراميه الاطراف في هذه الولايه
من مجموع من السودان
هل في مستشفيات خرجت عن الخدمه دكتور نعم
ام لا من مجمل 134 مستشفى
لتوفير الخدمه هذا الكلام واضح
ساعيد صيغه السؤال هل هناك مستشفيات خرجت
عن الخدمه دكتور ام لا بالطبع 39 مستشفى
منذ اليوم الاول لعدم توفير البيئه الامنه
للمرضى طيب ماذا عن عن نقص في
الاجهزه الطبيه ماذا عن المواد الطبيه هل
هذا ايضا يهدد عمل بعض المستشفيات كيف
نتكلم عن اجهزه هذه الاجهزه
الاجهزه تستهلك يعني تدمر
الاجهزه موجوده
هل هناك طبيه
موجوده لدينا كما قلت لك هنالك صعوبه في
الحركه في بعض المستشفيات التي تمتاز
بالتردد العالي وامنا هذه المستهلكات لكل
المستشفيات وهي تبع مستشفيات متاخمه
اليوم حينما نتحدث ارجو يعني ان يكون صدرك
رحب يا دكتور
بالتالي تستمع لي اذا تكرمت دكتور صوتي
جدا جدا
مطلقه مهنيه مطلقه
يا دكتور هل هناك مستشفيات حول تحولت الى
سكنات عسكريه من قبل طيب كم مستشفى نعم 12
مستشفى حولت الى سكنات الدعم السريع وهذه
المعلومه لا ينطق بها المتحدث هذا لا يحدد
ما هي الجهه التي اعتددها على سته اسعافات
هي هي وتدعم السريع طب شو رايك انت يعني
الدكتور حضرتك انت تتبناه وتقول لي اياها
الموقف اتمنى من
ان يكون صادقا للتاريخ ان يقول هذه
المعلومات رجائي ان تترك الدكتور عطيه
وتعطيني الحقائق حضرتك يا دكتور محمد يدين
هذا الانسان والبعيد عن اخلاقيات الشعب
السوداني والبعيد عامه
الاخلاقيات الدوليه دكتور ايضا الدكتور
للمدنيين وللعسكرين على حد سواء طيب عطيه
عبد الله ليس معنا الان لكن يا دكتور محمد
ارجو ان تعطيني حضرتك هذه الوقاء يبدو انك
لا تريد الاستماع الي يا دكتور محمد اعتذر
اذا كان غير موجود معكم ولكن استمعت الى
مداخلتي
انا استفهم منك اذا تكرمت
هذه الفرصه لتوضيح الحقائق
دكتور الان اعطيني حقائق امام الناس اليوم
طيب غير الخرطوم ماذا عن المستشفيات
والوضع الطبي في عموم السودان دارفور على
سبيل المثال
هنالك ولايه امنه مستقره ياتيها عيشها
رغدا وقطاع الصحي يعمل بكفاءه 100%
ولايتين متاثرات منذ يوم 15 وحتى ولايه
الخرطوم بصوره كبيره وولايه غرب دارفور
الان وزاره الصحه الاتحاديه تعيد اجراءات
اعاده الخدمه لولايه لولايه غربي دارفور
وهي ولايه صغيره
الان من مجمل 18 ولايه الولايتين
المتاثرات بصوره كبيره ولايه الخرطوم
وولايه غربي دارفور التي مازال
يحدث
الاصابات في غرب دار فرو هل لديك احصائيه
73 اصابه
وخمسين خمسين وفاء من الطرفين المدينين
والعسكريين نعم نحن نتحدث حتى حتى اليوم
ولا حتى يوم امس
حتى اليوم حتى اليوم صباحا
نعم هذه ايضا المستشفيات تقدمها تقدم
الرعايه الطبيه بالحد الادنى
بالحد الذي يضمن تقديم الخدمات على
المستوى الطاري وشك القاري على جرح الحرب
والامراض المزمنه
طيب هذه هي استراتيجيه عمل الصحه في ازمه
في الازمات والكوارث الطبيعيه والانسانيه
اها طيب ماذا عن ماذا عن الممرات الامنه
دكتور محمد ابراهيم عبد الرحمن المتحدث
باسم وزاره الصحه في السودان ما الذي
تطلبونه هل يكون هناك ممرات امنه لايصال
المواد الطبيه العاجله ما المشاكل امامكم
المشاكل
امامنا لا نستطيع ان نتكاهم بانه هذا
المسار امن ربما بعد ساعه او دقيقه يكون
غير امن لانه الحرب الان في الخرطوم هي
حرب مدن يوجد بها كروه فرع ولكن المسلسلات
التي تعمل الان هي بعيده كلاما عن مناطق
الاشتباكات منذ يوم مستشفيات طرفيه اخي
الكريم المستشفيات هذه موزعه على رقعه
جغرافيه كبيره جدا
هي ليست مكدسه كلها في مركز الخرطوم هنالك
اكثر من 70 مستشفى في اطرافه الخرطوم امنه
منذ يوم 15 تقدم الخدمه الطبيه هنالك
مستشفى الكباشي مستشفى
الجبل اولياء مستشفى الفتح مستشفى الراجحي
هل سمع اخي الكريم بهذه الذي دخل قبل قليل
هذه
المستشفيات طيب ماذا عن المخازن الطبيه
دكتور محمد هل هي امنه ام تعرضت
له بعض المحال التجاريه من نهب وغيرها
لم تتعرض الى اي الى اي
ضرر
هنالك مجموعه من المخازن الان في كل
المناطق الكبرى بحدهم الخرطوم الان تقوم
بتوزيع المستهلكه في المستشفيات القريبه
منها
المستوى الذي تضرره هو في غرب دارفور وفرح
به السيد وزير الصحه الاتحادي دكتور هيثم
طيب في غرب بدار فورد ما هي اذا تكرمت ما
هو الوضع ايضا لهذه المخازن توضح لي اذا
تكرمت
وضع دارفور الان عملت وزاره الصحه
الاتحاديه بدعومات للمستهلكات الطبيه من
الولايات المتاخمه لولايات غربور والتي
تمتاز بالامان
ولايات كردفان الثلاث ولايات
دارفورات طيب يعني اليوم الخرطوم والمخازن
لا تعاني من اي نقص هل تؤكد ذلك الدكتور
محمد ابراهيم
[موسيقى]
نعاني من صعوبه في توصيل المستهلكات لبعض
المستشفيات التي مازال الاشتباك حولها
[موسيقى]
شكرا الدكتور محمد ابراهيم عبد الرحمن
المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه في السودان شكرا
جزيلا لك
قرر الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
غوتي ارساله منسقه لاغاثه في حالات
الطوارئ ووكيل الامين العام للشؤون
الانسانيه مارتن جريفيث الى السودان
لاستكشاف في سبل تقديم الاغاثه الفوريه
لملايين الاشخاص الذين انقلبت حياتهم راسا
على عقب بسبب القتال الدائري في السودان
من جانبه اكد المتحدث باسم الامين العام
للامم المتحده ستيفاندو جاريك ان المفوضيه
الساميه للامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين
تخططوا لاستقبال اكثر من 800 الف شخص قد
يفرون من القتال في السودان الى الدول
المجاوره من وادي
يدعم صندوق الامم المتحده للسكان الشركاء
على الارض بالرعايه الصحيه المنقذه للحياه
ومعدات الولاده الامنه تخطط المفوضيه
الساميه للامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين
بالتشاور مع الحكومات والشركاء لاستقبال
اكثر من 800 الف شخص قد يفرون من القتال
في السودان الى الدول السبع المجاوره تؤكد
احدث الارقام من فرقنا على الارض ان 73
الف شخص قد وصلوا الى البلدان المجاوره
مما في ذلك اللاجئون السودانيون ولا سيما
من جنوب السودان
في تشاد نزح ما يقرب من 20000 لاجئ سوداني
اغلبيتهم من النساء والاطفال منهم من
يعاني من امراض تنفسيه خطيره غير ان
اليونيسف حذرت من البقاء في قريه كفرون
الشاديه خوفا من موسم الامطار المقبل
خطا نهايتها عصيه طريق اللجوء يطول وصلنا
وحدات الى تشاد لاجئه سودانيه دون مواعيد
بعضهن تمكنا من الدفع فقل عليهن عبء
الطريق نساء واطفال هربوا من حرب اشتعلت
فجاه خيار اللجوء لا مفر منه ضمن حرب
بحصيله كبيره للقتله ضرب البيوت وقد قتلوا
ثلاثه نفر اربعه كده عشان كذا
استقروا هنا على الحدود الارشاديه
السودانيه كبرات السن لم تعد لهن القدره
على المضي بينما الاطفال اغلبهم يعانون من
امراض تنفسيه وسوء تغذيه
20,000 لاجئ سوداني استقروا في قريه كفرون
تشاديه قريه تفتقر لاساسيات الحياه وضروره
تغيير المكان باتت حتميه
اذا فشلنا في التحرك الان سيفوت الاوامر
سياتي موسم الامطار قريبا واذا لم نقدم
مساعده للناس سيتم اغلاق الطريق وسيظل
اللاجئون عالقين هنا
يبدو ان البقاء هنا طويل مخيم اللجوء باتت
تتشكل ملامحه عشرات الاسقف واعمده علها
تشد بيت لاجئ الى حين عوده غيداء السالم
العربيه
وفي تطورات عمليات الاجلاء قالت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان قوتها الجويه قامت
باجلايه اكثر من 200 شخص من الاراضي
السودانيه بناء على قرار من الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين
مضيفه ان اربعه طائرات عسكريه قامت
بعمليات الاجلاء حيث شملت موظفها البعثه
الدبلوماسيه الروسيه في السودان والمكاتب
التنفيذيه لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه
وعائلاتهم من مواطن روسيا وولدان رابطه
الدول المستقله وعدد من الدول الاجنبيه
الصديقه
في مشهد مؤثر لعمليه اجلاء نقل نقل افراد
نقل افراد من البحريه السعوديه شابا من
ذوي الاعاقه من ميناء بورسودان الى سطح
سفينه الدرعيه المتجهه الى جده نتابع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
عربيه ثانيه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
في سياق ذاتها افاده المتحدثه باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه بان بلاده نجحت في
اجليه اكثر من الف مواطن امريكي من
السودان عبر ثلاث قوافل في وقت كان البيت
الابيض قد اعلن نشر طائرات لمراقبه عمليات
الاجلاء
اي عدد محدد نصح عنه لاعداد المواطنين
الامريكيين الذين غادروا السودان
المواطنون الامريكيون هم من يتخذون القرار
بشان المغادره بحسب اولوياتهم تواصلنا
خلال هذه الازمه مع اكثر من 5000 مواطن
امريكي مقيم في السودان واجلينا الفا
مواطن منهم عبر ثلاث قوافل
كما تمنت الخارجيه الامريكيه جهود
السعوديه في استقبال المواطنين الامريكيين
وايضا للمساعده في عمليات الاجلاء من
السودان عموما
اود القول ان السعوديه لعبت دورا مهما ليس
فقط في استقبال مواطنين لكن في دعم
الرباعيه وكانت حلقه وصل في الدفع بتمديد
هدنه الاثنتين وسبعين ساعه
والله هذا يعني شعور لا يوصف انه الواحد
يكون كله يعني هو والاسره كلهم بامان
الناس كتير هناك عندها مشاكل ما قادره ما
عندها فلوس ما عندها مصاري ناس كتير معلقه
نحمد الله سبحانه
لاهل المملكه هل هذا الاستقب
ال
[موسيقى]
في بورتسودان تستمر عمليه اجلاء رعايه
الدول الاجنبيه من شرق السودان حيث غادر
اكثر من 16 الف طالب باجلاء غادروا البلاد
خلال الايام الماضيه
عشره ايام مضت على اول عمليه اجلاء لرعايه
دول الاجنبيه من شرق السودان نحو مختفي
الدول العالم عبر ميناء بورسودان وعبر
مطهرها الدولي اكثر من عشرين رحله بحريه
تمت حتى الان ونحو 45 رحله جويه من مطار
بورسودان الدولي تستمر عمليات الاجلاء دون
توقف غير ان اوضاع الرعايه السوريين
المطالبين بجلائهم تشكل استثناء هنا عم
نطلب نروح جده
نروح جده وبعدين نروح نحن اي بلد
فيزا اربيل عراق مصر اي اي مكان ما حدا
سال علينا العيال في الشوارع النساء
الشباب مضى معه مصاري هاي ما تصرف الحمد
لله الشعب السوداني ما هو مقصر ابدا لا من
اكل لا من ملبس لا من ماء
طيب لايمت هذا الوضع ازمه الاخرى تشهدها
المنافذ نحو الخارج حيث يواجه السودانيون
المقيمون في عدد من الدول ظروفا صعبه يقول
كثير منهم ان اوضاعهم لا تحتمل تاخر
اجراءات مغادرتهم للسودان نحن عندنا
اقامات عندنا زيارات يعني في ناس غ
امات خط طيب نحاول الحكومه واقفه والبلد
واقفه دي مشكله برضو
كل السلطات يا جماعه انه لو في امكانيه
توفره لنا بواخر نحن بحقنا بتذاكر بنشتري
كل السودانيين
مستطيعين انهم يدفعوا حق التذاكر بس ما
موجوده بواخر نحن كسودانيين مقيمين في
السعوديه انا ناشط السلطات السودانيه
والسلطات السعوديه انه يسرعوا في اجراءات
اجلانا من مدينه بورسودان الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه لانه عندنا طلبه عندهم
جامعات وعندهم اسر
الشفقانين شديد ولازم يصلون باسرع وقت
للمواجهات المسلحه ارتدادات مختلفه يامل
كثيرون هنا ان لا تتمدد لتشمل قطاعات اخرى
نزار البغداوي لقناتي العربيه والحدث
مدينه بورسودان الشرقيه السودان
وعلى الحدود المصريه السودانيه تستمر
عمليات استقبال السودانيين الفارين من
الاشتباكات في بلادهم الى مصر اغلب
القادمين ياتون من خلال منفذ قسطل البري
ومن بعد يصلون لمدينه ابو سمبل عن طريق
عبارات نهر النيل احمد عثمان معه التفاصيل
نحن الان امام المرسى النيلي لمدينه ابو
سمبل في انتظار العبارات النيليه القادمه
والتي يستقلها السودانيون القادمون عبر
منفذ قسطل البري في اصعب من كيد كونك تخلي
دارك
بدايه الحرب في المنازل انعطاع التيار
الكهربائي الميه ما فيش ما فيش ولا حاجه
وعلى الرغم من استمرار تدفق القادمين من
السودان الى مصر باعداد كبيره الا ان هناك
من يفضل استقلال نفس الحافلات للعوده الى
السودان حاليا السودان في ازمه
واهالي الخرطوم كلهم جايين الى مصر هذا
المكان يعد مكانا للراحه للقادمين
المرهقين من السودان قبل ان يستانفوا
رحلاتهم مره اخرى سواء الى اسوان او الى
القاهره وجدنا تعاون طيب جدا حقيقه من
اخواننا المصريين كانهم اخواتنا يعني ومع
غروب الشمس تتوقف حركه العبارات النيليه
لينتظر الجميع سطوع شمس يوم جديد لكل من
يريد ان يذهب او ياتي الى الاراضي المصريه
من السودان احمد عثمان لقناتي العربيه
والحدث من مدينه ابو سمبل محافظه اسوان
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات